je vais commencer à 20 kg
et normalement les dernières c'est 28
voire 30 kg encore une séance intensive
pour Muriel Beauvillain cette yvelinoise
originaire de mitainville s'entraînait
actuellement à Rambouillet en vue du
championnat du monde de culturisme
naturel la sportive de 50 ans a été
sacré deux fois vice championne de
France et trois fois viches championne
d'Europe depuis le mois de janvier je
suis en préparation on m'a dit qu'elles
étaient qualifiées pour Europe et France
donc deux mois après encore de prépa et
là comme dit qu'on m'a dit que j'étais
sélectionné pour pour monde j'ai calculé
août septembre octobre novembre encore 4
mois de prépa j'ai fait aller on vit
qu'une fois Muriel développe sa passion
pour le culturisme après plusieurs
années de dépression son conjoint lui
fait découvrir cet univers et
l'encourage à se dépasser la sportif
décide de relever le défi avec ses
conseils avec sur le Zen intermittent
sur le jeune hydrique mêlée à une
activité sportive intensive voilà il m'a
embarqué là dedans moi j'y suis allé
parce que je suis une fonceuse elle est
arrivée chez nous elle faisait un peu
plus de 100 kg et Muriel aujourd'hui est
un corps bas de culturisme fitness parce
que elle a aussi cette féminité qui est
à l'approche du sport la championne se
présentera dans 6 catégories différentes
pour le championnat du monde elle
défilera en robe de soirée dans la
catégorie Miss run away Muriel tient
s’éloigner des clichés autour du
culturisme féminin de casser les codes
de casser les produits G sur le fait
qu'on peut pas être musculaire et
féminine le regard des gens de façon
qu'on fasse ça fera parler qu'on fasse
pas ça fera parler donc à un moment faut
il faut dire basta et puis je fais ce
que je veux et je quitte ma vie la
sportive exerce en parallèle le métier
d'auxiliaire de vie ses responsable
était d'abord surpris par son physique
atypique ils m'ont vu déjà tatouer voilà
donc déjà ça peut faire tiquer pas mal
de petites mamies et Papi mais ils
reconnaissent
volontiers que
voilà c'est c'est qu'une apparence
j'adore
m'occuper de ces personnes leur rendre
service être à leur à leur écoute le
championnat du monde de culturisme
naturel se tiendra à Prague les 18 et 19
novembre prochain la sportive a lancé
sur Internet une cagnotte Leetchi pour
l'aider à accomplir son rêve de médaille